don't bring anyone love into this well
how do you feel with the body change
that you've just gone through I mean do
you feel like you want to go out on the
beach and show people your body now no
no I I think it's you know it's
different I was actually telling someone
about it's like you the change happens
with with like with your weight and
everything slowly yeah and I think it
just you kind of get reinforces to you
like oh like this still sucks pretty
badly like my body like oh like you're
still so pretty fat and it's been a lot
of weight is gone but then I I always
try to remind myself of like how getting
out of shape actually took a long time
because what happens is like when you're
in it when you really are like really
eating well and working out it can be
frustrating when you just some random
day you're like I haven't eaten poorly
in a month and I've done nothing but
work out and I mean you just see like
your fat shitty flaws uh-huh yeah that
sucks but then you go like yeah but to
get out of shape it wasn't like I ate
three bad meals you know I mean it was
neglect and sitting and eating shitty
food for years to put on that weight so
yeah a month or two months or six months
is not going to be like all that all
that bad shit is gone it takes a long
long time yeah yeah but I think I mean
with me like I definitely don't feel
like oh wow this is like I joke around
you know like I know T's Bert and you
know but like I know I feel like I'm in
terrible you look great Tommy I mean I
compliment you every day you do you look
great well thank you handsome like your
face is so different your body looks
fantastic I think I mean you look great
heavy thankfully I like you both ways I
feel like you're skinny yeah you
definitely tolerated that tolerate it
how about your body you sucked off the
the mom you weight fast thank you yeah I
got real fat now you know you just don't
eat carbs or sugar have fun no alcohol
you must be suffering it's just you have
to suffer that's just it
yeah there's no easy way right you just
suffer well I guess it's a matter of
like your palate I think
for some people you get addicted to
carbs and so their withdrawal from carbs
and sugars is very intense intense and I
think for some people they just were
never that into carbs so it's not that
big a deal
hi there yeah when I think about yeah
I've had I I'm not even gonna say out
loud what I want to say why well no I
should because I can tell you how
horrifying it was to be that skinny when
I was little I literally eat anything
that I want yeah no I get it man be good
but everyone had like I don't know man
everyone has their own issue with
different things yeah so it's like I've
never had for me it's definitely food
and I definitely was eating a crazy like
I was thinking about once you make a
transition and and for a while you're
conscious of your eating and you go how
I used to eat was so insane yeah oh yeah
and like what about like eating with
normal people and and like they would
you know they would like a regular
person would see one of my meals as like
an in don't like a vacation meal I do
this every day and I would eat just like
with just no regard for it if you mean
like a regular meal at a restaurant what
you would order like an appetizer an
entree and a dessert 100% yeah and like
and and maybe like order another thing
that like I just want to try that and
and like another entree or side maybe
both no sure but I wouldn't even like I
wouldn't if I can even process it and
like I would have if I was on the road I
would have breakfast I would have
something like rich and fatty but then I
would be like I got some sweet so I have
like a waffle
uh-huh and then like if they're like
have you seen this bakery that has like
they have amazing croissants I'd be like
let's go let's go try it
yeah I mean I think I'm gonna throw up
was wait like an hour yeah and then when
I'm done I want to digest like I just
wouldn't I wouldn't think that I
wouldn't even think it was that much of
an indulgence yeah I would think
remember you know Tommy we used to at
our old house and beg and redonda the
sand we saw you we used to make brownies
I would I would bake brownies like every
night and then every night and then we
would eat like half
the tray nice and hot put some ice cream
on that sir I'm like well no wonder you
know we got here's the other thing
before I always because before we
invited the public to shame us about
being fat like Burt and I specifically
and we did this weight loss challenge
yeah dude when I would post things on
social media maybe one out of 400
comments would be about being fat nobody
would say anything to me nobody was like
you're fat one person might you know
you're like oh this guy's a dick because
you're built to be fat you got the bill
I have a big fat a great thing to say
you're right if you are built to be so
people would just be like it's fine yeah
built to be fat that's a good name for a
special shit I hate now you t-shirt shot
I just shot it in a special and and I
submitted the title but I think it might
[Laughter]
mean you've got the face for it you've
got a big head yeah yeah shoulders are
broad and you had a beard into that
forget it yeah you know what I might do
put on a hundred pounds and have another
special called built to be right
[Music]